le salon du bourget vient de se refermer
cette semaine nous vous proposons de
revenir sur ce secteur de l'aéronautique
sur saint quentin en yvelines premier
volet de notre dossier aujourd'hui lundi
nous partons dans les coulisses du
rapprochement entre le groupe safran et
l'équipementier zodiac aerospace
explications à nicolas landry stéphane
servant ce n'est plus qu'une question de
mois un géant français de l'aéronautique
devrait naître d'ici la fin de l'année
un projet solidement implanté dans les
yvelines safran a décidé de racheter lee
blinois zodiac aerospace une opération
financière chiffrée à 8,7 milliards
d'euros
spécialisée dans la fabrication des
moteurs le groupe safran avait déjà fait
une op à associer à une fusion qu'en
janvier dernier une offre rejetée à
l'époque avant qu'une nouvelle
proposition soit faite au mois de mai un
nouveau format de rapprochement entre
safran et zodiac aerospace qui doit
encore recevoir les autorisations des
autorités de la concurrence qui doit
aussi recevoir les l'accord des
instances représentatives du personnel
et si tout se passe bien l'offre de
safran sera lancée en fin d'année et
aboutira concrètement au début de
l'année 2018
mais il est vrai que safran et zodiac
sont tous deux implantés dans les
yvelines et il est très probable que
l'implantation dans les yvelines
continuera à se développer pour soutenir
le développement de l'industrie
aéronautique zodiac aerospace 120 ans
d'histoire depuis 2007 le groupe
focalise son activité uniquement dans
l'aéronautique
installé à plaisir c'est un poids lourd
du secteur dans les yvelines en 2016 il
réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 5,2
milliards d'euros un résultat adossé à
la production d'équipements en cabine
sièges masques à oxygène ou encore
système numérique
plusieurs outils fabriqués notamment à
plaisir un site employant mille trois
cents personnes montre aujourd'hui sur
ce salon du bourget une sonde de
jaugeage de carburant qui utilise la
fibre optique
et qui rend les avions qui utilisent de
plus en plus de composites plus sur
cette sonde a été développé à plaisir
par nos ingénieurs en coopération avec
notre autre site de roche la molière
mais on est extrêmement fier de
présenter cette innovation qui a été
retenue par boeing pour son boeing 777 x
qui arrivera d'ici 2019 2020 dans les
investissements du futur nous
investissons sur l'avion de demain à
l'avion plus sûr plus économes en
carburant grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
une utilisation des innovations
technologiques préconisée par le
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre chargé du numérique
c'est impressionnant de voir le rôle du
numérique dans toutes les entreprises
qu'on a vu cet après midi que ce soit
dans les start up ou dans les grands
groupes on voit qu'aujourd'hui toutes
les technologies elle passe par la mise
en oeuvre de technologies numériques qui
vont réinventer à la fois le métier
inventé l'utilité et réinventer la façon
de fabriquer la façon de faire est donc
ce qu'ils ont raison sur l'industrie
c'est une vraie l'invention de ces
usages
un développement qui pourrait
s'accentuer avec le rapprochement entre
zodiac aerospace et safran de nouvelles
innovations pourrait naître dans les
yvelines